Hello, everyone.
I'm Dr. Thomas Chan,
and this is Pediatric
Neurology 1.
Here's my email,
and contact me if
you have any
questions or anything.
All right, so these are
the session objectives.
Basically, we're
going to talk about
pediatric seizures
and some other issues
that are non-seizure
-like conditions
but have neurological
issues or signs
or symptoms.
And yeah, and away we go.
All right, so here's
the definition
of seizures. I reviewed
your previous
epilepsy lecture.
And yeah, you're
gonna get a lot of
this so you can feel
free to read through
it on your own if
you're interested.
All right, so
the main thing in
pediatrics and seizures
is that it doesn't
always look like
a typical seizure,
right? So seizures
come in many, many
forms, but most
of us think of
seizures as the full
shaking, stiffness,
eyes rolling,
chattering teeth or
biting your tongue,
maybe even incontinence.
So that's a very
classic seizure,
right? You're not with
it anymore. But in
kids, it could be
much, much more subtle,
just blank stares,
not aware of the
environment. could be just
random falling like
atonic seizures just
lose tone or just
abnormal posturing or just
one arm shaking like
for some reason and the
kid is like mom what's
going on so that
could definitely be a
seizure as well all right
infants could be even
more subtle because
they can't talk and
kids you know infants
you know have immature
brains in general so
they just do weird things
in general so a lot
of parents will come
to a pediatrician is
this normal is that
normal okay so you always
have to have high index
of suspicion luckily
most things are normal
it's not anything
serious but um sometimes
it's it's hard to
tell because parents
are just describing
something and unless
you see it yourself um
it's it's hard to say
luckily these days
everyone has a cell
phone and can uh you know
they're always video uh
camera uh videotaping
their kids and uh So
these days, you know,
we're able to review
a lot of home videos
about these kids doing
things. And it's actually
super useful for
a pediatrician and
neurologist because the
truth is most health care
providers don't actually
see the seizure.
So infants, they
could be lip smacking,
just being normal babies.
And then they just,
you know, their lips
move funny. okay even
though they're not
like eating you know
anything that's kind of
rhythmic or repetition
repetitious uh you
you really worry
about uh or and um
and or persistent like
it keeps on coming back
and maybe even getting
worse those are
those are the things
that make you make you
uh wonder like is this
something truly
neurological going on it
could be just startles
or jerks now all
babies do you know
just like us when we're
going to kind of going
to sleep You just
kind of have a little
**** once in a while.
But again, once in a
while, it's fine. If
it happens a lot,
that's worrisome, okay?
Eye blinking, eye
rolling, you know.
Obviously, the eye
rolling is much more
obvious, like eye
rolling behind your head.
But sometimes just
subtle blinking.
Now, we do know
kids have tics. And
that's very, very
common in childhood
age to have tics.
But, you know,
babies, young babies
don't really have
tics. So if you see
this rhythmic blinking
in babies, it's a
little bit abnormal,
okay? Again,
repetitive movements.
Sometimes it
could be just like
they start breathing
abnormally,
and these shudder or
what they call shiver
attacks can happen
as well, all right?
Again, very, very subtle.
It's really helpful
to have a parent
describe it well or
have a video camera,
okay? So neonatal
seizures can be, you
know, do happen. And
obviously you think
that is an insult,
right? So it could be
low sugar, hypoglycemia,
low sugar in a
Q phase, or just
chronically low sugar
can actually damage
the brain, obviously.
Low oxygen,
electrolyte ambalances,
obviously sepsis or
infection is bad,
bleeding, metabolic
derangements, okay?
You always want to
be able to, you know,
get a good history
from the parents.
So, you know, our
job is as clinicians,
students, whoever's
getting the history, try
to get as much detail
about what exactly
happened, when it
happened, what was the
surrounding situation,
okay, how long it lasted,
anything that's kind
of life-threatening.
Most parents, when
they see a seizure,
they're calling 911
right away, and time
just kind of, like,
just, you lose sense
of time. So a seizure
lasting two, three,
four minutes can
feel like an hour or
half an hour. and
that's what parents will
tell you the parents
will tell you it's
been like you know
i think it's 30
minutes and you see
later on you see how
important it is to
have a little timing um
from it and again what
happened afterwards
right the child was
child completely back
to normal had a seizure
and all of a sudden
it's like hey mom i'm
good but what happened
why are you guys crying
you know uh or did
they go to sleep for
a long time or they
were out of it and they
kind of had to like
slowly be ******* to
get back to normal right
so that's what we call
post ictophase for
what happened afterwards
all right so this
picture describes like
what you should do
what you should and
should not do so you
should try to time
the seizure right so I
always tell parents if
it ever happens again
look at look at the
time take two seconds
to look at the time
and on your watch maybe
when you're calling
911 and and then just
try to remember it and
usually when you do
that they'll realize
when everything stopped
it was only like two
three minutes okay
make person comfortable
lying to side so
sometimes especially
infants or children you
know you have foaming
at the mouth or you
sometimes even *****
from from all from all
the commotion and you
know you don't want
to aspirate that so
just having them on the
side so we just kind
of leak out but don't
put your finger or
anything else in the
mouth sometimes they'll
try to keep them
from choking uh they'll
keep them trying to
keep them from biting
their tongue that's
all bad stuff because
you can injure the
oropharynx now they're
bleeding uh and uh or
you induce vomiting
which is even worse so
uh biggest thing is like
if they're chattering
biting the tongue
it's okay just just
leave them alone okay
all right and we hear
the first case where
the 15 month old male
No past medical
history, so completely
normal infant,
developmentally normal.
Came to the ER after
having a seizure
that lasted less
than five minutes,
okay? So less than
five minutes. You
see why this is
important later on.
Shaking all over,
eyes rolling in the
back, so classic
tonic-clonic seizure,
okay?
Afterwards, went
to sleep, okay?
History, mild cold, but
no fever. but in the ER,
take vitals, it
was a 103 fever. So
now there's a big
fever, okay? And on
examination, normal
child, maybe you
figure out there's
an ear infection,
which is probably
causing a fever and the
child looks fine, alert,
responsive, doesn't
seem meningitic or
lethargic or irritable.
All right, so this
is a classic febrile
seizure. And the main
thing is that obviously
it has to be associated
with a fever, right?
That's what I call
the febrile seizure.
And often it's not
just how high the
temperature is. So a lot
of parents are always
worried like, oh, when
it hits 103.5, 104,
the brain's going
to melt and things
like that. No, in
this case, a lot of
times, just like
in the case study,
parents didn't even
know the child was
going to have a
fever. Otherwise they
would have given some
Tylenol ibuprofen.
In this case,
it was the rate
of rise as the
fever's going up.
it kind of
triggered the brain
because it lowers the
seizure threshold,
right? So the brain's
kind of immature when
they're young and that
fever lowers the seizure
threshold and they
have a seizure, okay?
The classic one is
six months, classic,
well, I would say most
people prescribe to
this timeline is six
months to five years. So
not super young, so
I'm not talking about
neonatal, very young
infant period, period,
but not a very old
child as well. So
sometimes, you know,
when they do have
these febrile
seizures, and I'll see
later, if often very
recurrent, you can
just kind of have to
say, hopefully, he
or she will outgrow
it, because usually
lasts till five
years of age, okay?
Should last in less
than 15 minutes,
tonic-clonic,
so the classic
shaking all over seizure,
postictal phase after
so they either sleep
after or they get very
very quiet okay uh
it's almost like the
brain's recovering so when
they have a tonic
-clonic seizure it's like
the whole brain is
discharging just imagine
whole brain just ran
a marathon right away
and so it needs to rest
okay it's very very
common and this is
important as well no
prior neurological issue
so there was no history
of meningitis it
wasn't a ********* baby
there's no metabolic
abnormality um it's a
normal, normal young
child or infant, okay?
And no history of a
previous a-febrile
seizures, okay?
So if you had a
history of a seizure
in the past would
not associate with
fever, you wouldn't
classify this as
a febrile seizure.
So basically the febrile
seizures is important
because if you meet
this criteria of tonic
-clonic, less than 15
minutes, the right age,
one seizure in a 24
-hour period, right?
So you only get
one seizure in a
day, all right? And
then afterwards,
the child looks
fine. Then usually,
it's reassurance
to the parents
that this is just
a febrile seizure.
The fever lowered the
seizure threshold,
but that your child
should be, okay, we don't
need further imaging,
referrals, a lot of
workup, blood work,
spinal lumbar punctures,
but don't have to do
any of that, okay?
Again, provided the
child looks well, right?
And so no, usually
no further workup.
So again, they have
this criteria, simple.
It's what we call simple
febrile seizures.
It's all good,
right? So what if
it's not simple? What
if everything, it
lasted longer than 15
minutes, right? They
timed it. It was
definitely like a
25-minute seizure.
That's too long. Or it
wasn't a tonic-clonic
shaking all over,
a focal feature. It
was only like one
side was, all right?
That's, again,
abnormal, all
right? Outside the
age range, what
if it was like
a two-month-old?
No, too young, or
it could be called a
simple febrile seizure.
You want to work with
it. Or you have a
seven-year-old, and
there's a first seizure,
but it was a fever.
Again, outside the
age range. We're not
saying it won't be a
febrile seizure, but
it's got more complex
features, okay? Okay.
And again,
you know, so basically
simple febrile should
be this criteria.
Anything outside that,
it could be what we
say a complex febrile
seizure. And the
reason it's important
because usually a
complex febrile seizure,
we will do a workout.
We might do an EEG,
right? So there's a
baby with what does
a little cap of
electrodes, and that's how
we do EEGs in small
infants or young
children. All right,
that's an EEG there. You
can see there's a
blinking light there.
So sometimes
photostimulation, flashlights,
and sometimes you
can elicit a seizure.
Neurology referral,
very common.
We can talk to
parents about the risk
of recurrence and
future epilepsy because
all parents will
want to know. After
you make the
diagnosis of something
happening, they're
going to want to know,
one, was there something
they could have
did to prevent it?
In this case, no.
Did they do anything
to cause it?
No.
It wasn't their
fault. Our parents
have a little
guilt trip going
and it's
understandable. So they
want to know if
they did anything.
They didn't. And
a future risk
of, is it going
to come back?
Or is my child going
to be brain damaged?
Things like that.
So you have to know
enough about the
condition to talk to them.
Again, different
testing items.
Okay. So a little bit
more about febrile
seizure and epilepsy,
right? Because that's the
main question people
are going to want to
know is that when this
happens, simple febrile
seizure, and you say,
mom, everything's
good. You can go home.
We don't have to do
anything. I'm going to
give you a moccicillin for
the ear infection because
that's what caused
the fever. But in
general, there's nothing
much to do. Just give
Tylenol and ibuprofen
for the fever and then
just keep the baby
safe. Okay. But we do
have to let them know
that there's a good
chance that the next time
the child has a fever
or in the future, uh,
there's a good chance
that he or she may get
a seizure again,
same type of seizure,
simple febrile seizure,
but it can happen again.
All right. And the more
it happens, the more
likely it is to
happen. Right. So, you
know, that's common
sense. Uh, your brain is
kind of predisposed to
have these seizures. Uh,
it can go. So, and
I've had, um, you know,
several kids that,
uh, have had several,
several febrile seizures,
but luckily knock on
wood they've outgrown
it you know as after
they uh reached you know
gotten to like early
elementary school age
like six seven uh they
outgrew it and didn't
have um have a problem
afterwards okay uh
definitely genetic
susceptibility so half
the time when i have a
child with febrile
seizures you know there's
someone in the family
that had uh a seizure
disorder or febrile
seizures as well you hear
all the time parents
will not tell you this
when you're asking
about family history
unless you're asking
specifically about that
because the seizure
happened and they're like
oh yeah i remember that
did say that when he
was a young kid he had
he had seizures that
he outgrew okay they
you know they said
everything was fine and
he's fine now never had
a seizure since all
right there you go right
genetic susceptibility
the treatment all
right obviously if it
lasts for a long time you
you can give them anti
-seizure medications
but these are IV and
you need to be in a
hospital and start an
IV. When you're at home,
we can prescribe
what we call ******
diazepam, okay,
gel. So you can do
****** suppository.
So child seizing,
it's lasting for
a few minutes.
And I have my
trusted little baby,
they would go to the
medicine cabinet, they'll
have it ready and
they'll pop it into
the butt. It will get
absorbed and hopefully
it'll stop the seizure
most of the time you
know from experience
parents have it it's a
good thing to have
at home for prolonged
seizures but most times
by the time they get
it calm down unwrap it
figure everything out
call ems the seizure
stopped already okay
thank goodness all
right again neurologic
seizures are rare and
epilepsy frequency is
only a little bit above
general population.
So we do have to tell
them like, all right,
child had a
febrile seizure.
The risk of
seizure epilepsy
in general in the
population is only
1-2%. Your child may
be a little bit
higher, but it's not
like 30%. Your
child's going to have
epilepsy, but it's
a little higher.
Okay.
All right, let's
move on to another
condition. It's called
infantile spasms, also
known as West syndrome
sometimes. Truth
is most people use
infantile spasms, some
textbooks that you'll
see West syndrome.
So the biggest thing
is that it's a spasm.
It's a ****. It's
a significant ****.
And it sounds
benign, but it's not
benign. Because it
has a significant
EEG finding called
hypsyrhythmia,
which is a very
chaotic rhythm.
And it's a very, very
poor prognosis. So
you don't just tell a
parent like, you know
what? I know your kid's
jerking. And I just
want to make sure it's
not infantile spasm
because they're going
to go right at home,
Google it, and
they're going to read
about it and then
just freak out, right?
So you don't say
it unless you're
really, really sure.
And it's very, very
common. Again, it's
a very poor prognosis
with development,
the regression.
So these are kids
that maybe, maybe,
you know, he was
three, four months
and he was starting
to roll over.
And then now like a
month later where he
used to roll over,
now he's five months,
he's been having
these jerks and all of
a sudden now he can't
roll over anymore.
You know, I'm like,
so that's what we
call developmental
aggression. Or
maybe he used to be
able to sit up at
six, seven months
and now he can't
sit up anymore. Now
he's just kind of
like, you know,
doing, again, losing
his milestones.
All right.
So vast majority, I
showed you my baby
in this case because
usually it's a
very young infant.
All right. So in this
case, three to seven
months, the most
common onset that
they start, parents
start noticing there's
something wrong
with their baby, all
right? So less than
one year of age,
just like this baby,
all right?
Classic thing is this
jerking, all right?
Jerking with the
head. It's almost like
flexing, like they're
doing sit-ups, all right?
They're jerking
like this,
okay? And it's
repetitive,
recurred, and it's
happening more and
more where it's like,
oh, it was three or
four times a day, doc.
And then now, like
a month later, you're
like, he's doing
it like every hour.
And then, so that's
a very poor history
in that it's not
more likely to be
infantile spasms, okay?
And the majority of
children here, like
I said, will be
cognitively impaired
or have other
seizure disorders. So
it's not a great
thing to have, okay?
Hips arrhythmia, I
don't expect you guys
to be able to read
EEGs, right? So you're
not gonna be tested
on it. It's just
something I added in,
all right? And it's
been associated
with many things,
obviously brain injury,
okay? So meningitis,
hypoglycemia,
post-encephalitis,
birth asphyxia,
like hypoxia, all
right? But you
see, a third of
them are what we
call cryptogenic.
We never figure
out why the
child has a
damaged brain,
but it is damaged and
it's not good, all
right? And there's one
condition that it has
been associated with
is tuberous sclerosis,
okay? So in this
case, what we do, the
first sign of tuberous
sclerosis before all
the other things which
you learn about, I
think you had a lecture
on it, is what we call
ash leaf spot, all
right? It's like a
hypopigmented patch that
you may not be able to
see, but with the
woods lamp, you can
sometimes pick it up. So
we've had several cases
where we've diagnosed
or we suspected it
could be infantile
spasms. And then most
doctors, including my
office, we have a woods
lamp there to diagnose
different conditions
and you shine a woods
lamp and what you're
looking for is this
ash leaf spot, okay?
All right,
treatment is ACTH,
adrenocorticotropic
hormone.
Most people will
try that first.
Sometimes you have to go
to an antiepileptic
medication
or just keep on
playing around.
Some of these
kids keep on
involving the
seizure disorder,
and it can be very tough
to take care of them.
And no one really
exactly knows
how to control
it. You just
try your best
to control it.
All right, so let's do
something a
little bit easier.
and the by far more
and more common,
which is benign
myoclonus of infancy.
And this is just non
-epidoleptic
infantile spasms,
infantile spasms, but
it's not infantile
spasms. All right.
So it's just
like these little
jerks. So these kids,
babies, just
every once in a
while, we'll ****
once in a while.
Nothing, it's brief, it's
sporadic, it's
not progressive.
They're always, again,
infants. And it's
probably like a sign
of like brain's just a
little immature, but
nothing horrible.
Just like us, sometimes,
you know, you see
people sleep and they'll
just like **** once
in a while. It's kind
of like that. And
it's a very reassuring
sign of it. So parents
will, you know, give
me videos of their
children sleeping.
Is this normal, doc?
And I'll see it. I'm
like, yeah, that's
normal. As long as it's
not happening a lot.
And if it does happen in
clusters a lot, right,
then, you know, I've
had cases where,
you know, I'm like,
I'm not sure. I'll
send you to a
neurologist to get the
EEG done and it's a
normal EEG, right?
So it's not the
hip's arrhythmia
that makes you think
infantile spasms.
It's a normal EEG and
it slowly goes away.
Child is doing great
developmentally.
Starts turning,
sitting up,
starts walking,
no delays, we're
all good, okay? So
it's benign
myoclonus of infancy.
All right, absence
seizures. I know you
had a little bit on
absence seizures. So
it's usually childhood
age. So the classic
time where you think
of it is like an early
elementary school
kid, all right? And
they're saying their
parents, teachers
saying they're daydreaming
a lot. They're not
attentive or they have
to like, hey, hey,
Johnny, like pay
attention, right? Because
he's just all of a
sudden, huh? Yeah.
All right. Yeah, sure.
And yeah, so that's
the classic absence
seizures. Notice you
just kind of blank out,
but there's no loss of
tone, right? There's
no, like, falling,
you know. And when
they come back, they
just kind of go back to
what they think they
were doing, right?
So there's no, like,
real post-dictal phase.
They just kind of
blank out for a little
while. So it could
be very, very subtle.
And kids in general
daydream, we daydream,
right? You just lose
focus once in a while.
So it could be quite
tricky to, but you
have to have a
heightened expectation
of suspicion. If
you think about it,
you would send to
a neurologist and
they'll probably
get an EEG. And the
classic one is
around a three Hertz
spike and wave
discharge, right?
That's a very
classic board review.
You know, there's
certain things
that you shouldn't
remember. And that's
one of those,
absence seizures,
three Hertz spike
and waves. All right.
All right. And this
is this condition.
You see certain things
you can do sometimes
can elicit the seizure.
And one of this is
well documented. It's
the absence seizures.
If you make them
hyperventilate, you can
provoke the seizure.
OK, so so what you know
why to put a picture
here is a pinwheel.
Right. So how do you
tell a kid, you know,
a five, six year old
to hyperventilate?
You can't really,
they won't know what
you're talking about.
Or breathe fast.
They still won't know
what you're talking
about. So sometimes
you can get a pinwheel
and just keep on
blowing the pinwheel. I
don't have a pinwheel
on me. But in my
clinic, I actually
have a pinwheel next to
my desk, right? Because
everyone, you know,
every couple of years,
I need to take out
the pinwheel and just
have them blow just
to, you know, see
if I can provoke a
seizure, right? So let's
say blow the pinwheel,
right? Because it's
fun. And the faster
you blow, the faster
the pinwheel goes.
And then
sometimes you go,
okay, well, blow, blow,
right? So you see,
provoke the seizure.
All right, treatment,
ethyl suxamide,
which is the first
line therapy.
That's one of
those things you
should remember,
but you also see
sometimes people
using valproic acid.
All right, there are
some other things
you should know about.
we're going to leave
it for your pharmacology
lectures and
I've been tested on
that, that certain
other medications can
exacerbate it, okay?
All right, so now
we're going to
talk about another
type of epilepsy,
the common phrasing
outside in the
clinical world. A lot
of times we call it
Rolandic epilepsy, but
the true terminology
is benign partial
epilepsy with
central temporal
spikes. And it's really
completely in the
name. It's benign,
all right? It's a
partial epilepsy, so
it's not generalized
tonic-clonic, okay?
And it's usually
actually simple. So
usually the consciousness
is intact, right?
So very commonly,
it's happening when
they're falling
asleep or when they're
waking. And you'll
see this very, if you
become a pediatrician,
very common theme,
seizure or this abnormal
movement happened
when they were about
to go to sleep or
when they were just
about to wake up,
all right? Or parents
say, you know, what
the parents are
sleeping with their
children and they notice
the seizure. That's
always easy because
they can tell you
exactly when it started
and what happened.
or the times you
heard the history
also that they heard
the child gurgling
or making commotion
in their bedroom
and they went to
check on the child
and they noticed
them seizing, okay?
Again, that
childhood range,
all right? Five to
nine years of age,
but it could be,
you know, young
childhood to like
*******, okay? Okay,
classic EEG findings
is that central
temporal spike. All
right, so again, you're
not expected to
read EEGs, but it's
something that you should
remember, Rolandic.
And the reason it's
important is because
it's really an
excellent prognosis. So
usually they just go
away over time. By
the time they're
teenagers or preteens,
the seizure disorder
goes away. Like
I've had several
kids with reliantic
epilepsy and they
were on anti-epileptic
drugs because
they were having
issues. But sometimes
you don't have
to use it because
it's pretty benign.
And these days, the
anti-epileptic drugs,
we have more of them
with less side effects.
So it actually works
out pretty well.
I actually had a
case where it was a
new patient. And
parents brought this
child to me and they
said he has Rolandic
epilepsy. He has this.
And they described
it perfectly. And
he was on an anti
-epileptic medication.
And then they
said, well, the doctor
told me he was going
to have to take
this his whole life.
And I'm like,
really?
You sure it's
Rolandic epilepsy?
Because usually
Rolandic is, you know,
usually excellent
prognosis. Usually I
will outgrow it.
Like, this was, like,
he was kind of,
like, late elementary
school, maybe eight,
nine years of age.
And, you know, so we
got the old records,
everything, and
everything really checked
out that, yes, he
seemed to have Rolandic
epilepsy, classic EEG
findings. And then, you
know, I told mom,
like, you know what, I
think, you know, the
books say he should get
better. And the reality
is, you know, as
I followed him over
the years, it really
did. He got better,
took him off the anti
-epileptic drug at some
point. He never had a
seizure after that,
right? So this is why
it's important to be
able to tell parents
the correct things that,
just imagine his mom
thought her child was
going to have epilepsy
and need to be on
medication their whole
life and turned out,
no, that's not the
case. You know, he
can drive, he can go
swimming and really live
a normal life, okay?
All right. And what
this mom or whoever her
provider was probably
got it mixed up with
this condition, right,
which is juvenile
myoclonic epilepsy.
All right. It can look
very, very similar in
terms of the myoclonic
jerks. Okay. There's
a few different types
of seizures that's
associated with this one.
Sometimes they can
be generalized tonic
-clonic, and sometimes they
have absence seizures.
So it can be various
types. All right.
Usually it's adolescents
or young adolescents,
all right?
The one patient I have
that has this, he was
diagnosed in older
childhood, so he was
not a teenager yet,
all right? This case,
photosensitivity is common,
and sleep deprivation
or not sleeping enough
is a common trigger.
So what do teenagers
do very commonly?
They sleep late,
right? So sleep
deprivation is very, very
common, and they play
lots of video games. All
right, so video games,
you know, flickering
lights that can
definitely trigger and
that's the classic
history where they're not
sleeping or they're
taking a test, studying
for a comp and only
sleeping three, four hours
a night and then a
seizure was provoked.
And the reason I say
with that previous case,
the parent, you know,
the provider said he
was probably going to
have it for the rest
of his life. Because
in this case, juvenile
myoclonic epilepsy,
usually you actually have
a lifelong treatment,
right? So my patient
that has this diagnosis,
most likely he's
going to have to take
his anti-epileptic
medication his whole
life, right? And as a
teenager, he is not very
compliant. So like once
or twice a year, he
gets seizures because
he's not taking his
medication properly because
he's a teenager and
he doesn't want to.
So lifestyle
modifications,
again, things
that trigger the
seizures are
sleep deprivation.
Hydration is
always a good thing
and avoid flickering
lights. So
maybe not too
many video games,
concerts, things
like that, discos,
can, just to go back
one slide, in this
case, the classic
EEG pattern is a
four to six hertz
poly spike and wave
discharge, okay? So
juvenile myoclonic
epilepsy is, if you
make this diagnosis,
you know, most likely,
it's not hard to
control the seizure,
which is very good.
So just like my
patient that has this
diagnosis, when he
takes medication, he's
good. He doesn't
have seizures. But
problem is he doesn't
take it all the time.
All right, Lennox
-Gastaut syndrome.
I just want to
throw this in.
You're going to hear
it once in a while.
And it's really a type
of a severe seizure
syndrome, all right?
So severe seizure, it
can be associated with
tuberous sclerosis,
history of meningitis.
Usually you have
many different
types of seizures. A
lot of times when
they were infants,
they had infantile
spasms, and it progressed
to this severe
seizure syndrome.
And really not much
to know. I'm not
going to ask you on
the different EEG
patterns. I just want
you to have heard the
condition that it's
a bad prognosis,
all right? A lot of
these kids end up
with, again, just
like infantile spasms,
developmental delays,
many problems in
their life, okay?
Cognitive dysfunction,
sometimes,
you know, just
brain damage over
time, you know,
psychotic symptoms,
all right, again, here,
very hard to control.
Many of these kids,
if you encounter
them and you probably,
you'll be working
closely with a neurologist
with these kids,
they're on like two or
three anti-epileptic
medications, very,
very common, okay?
Some studies have
shown a ketogenic diet
sometimes can help
decrease the number
of seizures, okay?
But there's still
a lot we don't
understand about this.
all right here's a
little slide on the
different uh a little
summary so some of you guys
that like summaries
this is this is it
all right let's move on
to the next part which
is you know my child's
acting funny all
right and you're not
really sure if it's a
seizure or not all right
so we'll go over some
common some common
things okay so chorea
so chorea you're
going to learn in your
infectious disease
lectures whether you had it
already or in the future
you will you learn
about a rheumatic fever
due to group a strep
okay and one of the
complications in the
jones criteria is what
we call sitting him's
korea and it's it's
just this abnormal uh
involuntary movement
these kids like just
they constantly moving
they they just can't
stop okay so uh it's
very it doesn't look
like seizure and but you
can tell it's abnormal
right and luckily
most times over time
it's an autoimmune
phenomenon from the infection
over time these kids
can get better yeah
sometimes you give
them you know something
like howdol to to
kind of calm them down
but a lot of times you
just kind of hopefully
wait it out and it
could be months to years
the handwriting is
horrible because they
they have no voluntary
control over a
lot of things.
So these other things
can cause korea as well,
much less common,
but it's good to
know for your
differential diagnosis.
But if you go on YouTube,
I didn't put a link here,
but if you look up Sin
Him's korea, there's
several good YouTube
videos of parents that
have took videos and
posted it of their
kids, you know, for
education's sake. And it's
very interesting to
see it in real life.
Okay, dystonia.
We don't see too many
dystonic
reactions anymore.
But it's a, and there's
a reason because
the classic history,
and this is one
I encountered when
I was a resident,
was a child came
in and he was like,
just, it looked
like a seizure. It
looked like he was
having a seizure. it
was like his neck was
kind of like stiff
and he was like
really, really tight.
And attending at
that time realized
the history was
he was in the ER,
another ER two
to three days
prior. They gave
an anti-emetic.
Mom, of course,
doesn't remember what
the medication's name
is. But in the past,
we gave anti-emetics
that had like
phenylthiazines in it.
And that's classically
causing a dystonic
reaction, right?
And then once we
were able to, like,
get the proper history,
they started IV,
gave IV diphenhydramine,
and it just,
like, miraculously,
the minute we gave
the diphenhydramine,
it's like all
of a sudden you could
see the child relax,
and everything was
back to normal.
Okay, so it's
classic dystonia.
Again, you can see
videos of dystonic
reactions on
YouTube if you feel
like you have a
little extra time.
All right, Sandifer
syndrome is something
I see, like, once a
week. babies come in
uh and it's really just
uh it's just reflux
right so they're
sitting they just finish
eating now i'm
pressing on their belly
right because i'm
doing an exam and then
they just like they
just kind of stretch
out uh like uh and
they just kind of arch
back like that all
right and kind of looks
like a seizure if you
don't don't know what
you're looking at
but in this case they
just have some reflux
and just like when
we have reflux oh i'm
not it's not pleasant
And that's what the
kid's doing, right?
No eye rolling,
everything looks fine.
But it's good, it's
important to know because
it looks a lot like
the baby's having
like a tonic seizure,
but it's not, right?
Standard for syndrome
is just fancy
reflux, okay? And you
treat it like reflux,
all right?
This is a very,
very interesting
neurological issue
and it's called breath
-holding spells,
right? And it's
basically a temper
tantrum gone wild.
The classic history
is a two to three
-year-old, terrible
twos, they call it,
where they're having
a tantrum. They
were online at Target.
They picked up a
candy bar. And then
mom says, no, you
can't have the candy
bar. Put it back.
The child cries.
And it's like, you
took the candy bar
and you took it
out of hand. And
they're like, no, cry,
cry, cry, cry,
cry, cry, cry, cry.
They cry so much, they
turn blue, and they
literally passed out.
And sometimes when
they pass out,
they'll shake a little
bit, okay? So, because
your brain was actually
deprived of oxygen
for a short while.
But usually, once
they pass out, they
start breathing again,
right? Super scary.
I had one kid
in my practice.
Every time he came to
see us, he was a toddler.
He would cry, right?
because he didn't want
to be there and you
know he would have these
like he would like his
lips started turning
blue and i'm like
hey hey come on wait
wait you know just
kind of like try to
distract him uh just to
get him get him to breathe
um and like you know
eventually he outgrew
it after a few years
but it was like
every time he went in
me and mom would look
look at each other oh
here it comes again
he's gonna have another
breath holding spell
all right and it's again
And it's very, very
reassuring. You really
don't have to do
anything. It's important
to check for iron
deficiency anemia
because if you have less
hemoglobin, you're a
little anemic. You just
have less carrying
capacity of oxygen. So
maybe just if they
weren't anemic, they can
last like maybe five,
10 more seconds before
they like passed out.
And maybe by that
time, you could have
like snapped them out
of it, right? So this
is very, very common.
And yeah, I've seen
several cases of it
And it's really the
history that gives
it away The history
of a temper tantrum
And then they get blue
from crying And they
pass out or even
shake So if anyone has
ever seen someone
have a vasovagal
attack They pass out
and they're like, you
see them It's very
common, they'll shake
a little bit until
they come back Okay.
All right. There's
a different type of
breath holding spell.
It's a little bit more
severe type. It's
more like a sudden
onset, like a sudden
shock, surprise, and
they pass out. All
right. It's more of a
hypervagal response.
So some kids get that.
Even adults get that,
right? So you're at
a surprise birthday
party. Everyone goes,
surprise, and you
just pass out. All
right. But again, it
can be confused with a
seizure because when
you pass out, sometimes
you can be shaking.
So let's get
abnormal vagal response.
You can outgrow it.
There is a condition
called prolonged QT
syndrome that is very,
very similar where
a stimulus or a shock
can also cause you
to pass out. And
that's from arrhythmia.
So most of these kids,
I didn't write it
here, if you ever
have that history, you
would probably want
to do EKG to look for
a prolonged QT. You'll
get that next year
when you're doing
your cardio lectures.
All right.
Self-stimulation.
So this is weird,
but I've seen
it enough in my
career that when
these kids, and
it's usually like
a little toddler,
not quite in
elementary school,
maybe two, three
years old, they can
actually have an
****** by accident,
right? They're
like sitting on,
watching TV, they
have their teddy
bear or whatever
it is, and then
they just kind of
like, by accident,
create an ******,
and sometimes they
can actually look
like they're having
a seizure, right?
So one case I had
was the story a
parent told me, I
think my child had
a seizure, eyes kind
of rolled and she
got really stiff,
happened like a
couple of times.
I said, okay, you
got to go to a
neurologist, went
to a neurologist,
kind of lost
track. She didn't
really come
back to see me.
I saw the neurologist
at like a function,
like a party or something.
And I asked, oh,
did you see that patient
I sent you like a
month or two ago? and they
you know the neurologist
started laughing
started laughing and
they told me like oh
it was just a self
-stimulation thing you
know like i got it we got
on a video camera uh
we we saw exactly what
happened nothing
reassured i'm like really
it was self-stimulation
and that's exactly
what happened uh maybe
six months ago same
exact case uh except i
made a diagnosis this
time because the history
was you know she was
always in her like barbie
tent watching video
same exact situation
and then something
happened right she
didn't describe something
seizure but she's like
she's acting weird um
and uh you know so
again it's reassurance
um the biggest thing
is like reassure the
parents your child is
not a ****** deviant it
doesn't mean anything
it's just these things
just happen uh distract
the child uh keep
the child active and
the usual thing you know
from my experience is
it's the same situation
that causes them to
you know they're always
sitting like on the
sofa in that exact
corner watching tv when
they do this so just
kind of change it up you
know like put something
there so they can't
be in that same
situation and you can
usually uh yeah keep it
from happening anymore
okay because it's kind
of weird have that
talk with parents Okay,
ataxia, right? A
child who's like, you
know, not walking,
not walking well.
The most common, you
know, this is a good
differential, but by
far not exhaustive.
Many things can
cause ataxia, some
really bad and some
not too bad. Okay, so
I'll go over a few
of these here. All
right, the most
common two is acute
cerebellar ataxia
and benign position.
Okay, so acute cerebellar
ataxia. young child,
usually there's a
history of, you know,
they had a cold
recently, and a few weeks
later, he or she's not
walking right. Usually
gets better on his
own, versus if there's
like a brain tumor, it
wouldn't get better,
it would keep on
getting worse, right?
It's by far the
most common cause,
but a diagnosis of
exclusion, right?
If you look here,
there's a lot of bad
things that can cause
ataxia, Guillain-Barre,
hemorrhage, trauma,
toxic ingestions,
neuroblastoma,
right, tumors. So
there's a lot of bad
things. So you really,
a lot of times you
want it, you're going
to do some workup
on the child before
you say, give them
this diagnosis of
acute cerebral ataxia.
All right.
This thing can look
very, very similar.
They're not ataxic.
It's benign positional
vertical so it's more
that every once in
a while like an attack
happens and they
get unsteady so as
opposed to a taxi where
you're always like
not walking well for
like a week or two or
three or four um this
is more like this
kid is walking around
i have my little other
doll here i wasn't
sure i'm going to use
her so she's walking
around and she's
playing and all of a
what's going on i'm
confused right you can
see maybe eyes looking
around uh it's confused
they look confused
i don't know what to
do it's like it's okay
honey why don't you
stand i can't stand
daddy i'm i'm i'm i
can't stand right
that's a classic history
all right where uh all
of a sudden they get
confused it's like
they get it's like a
sudden shock of of
vertigo uh an unsteadiness
and they sit down uh
and that classic history
um is is all you need
all right and you
can make a diagnosis
of benign position of
vertigo all right so
a year ago i had a
cute little girl just
like she's actually this
size maybe like three
four years old and
it was happening several
times in in a week
um got us very worried
but the history was
very very classic um
i said it's benign
position of vertigo i
still end up sending
it to neurology because
it was happening it
was happening a lot.
But in the end, it did
over a course of
several weeks, she got
better. And then now, I
just saw her like last
month, and she's all
grown up, and doesn't
happen anymore. Okay,
so short lived, we
do think of it as a
migraine barrier. And
interestingly, this,
this little girl does
complain of headaches
once in a while by
patient. So it's probably
that, right, that,
you know, likely when
she grows up, to be
older, she will probably
have headaches or
migraines okay all
right a couple more
conditions ataxia
telangiectasia is all in the
name they're ataxic
and they have
telangiectasias telangiectasias
are abnormal blood
vessels all right that
look very distinctive
okay it could be in
the nose it could
be in the eyes using
the mucous membranes
okay it could be anywhere
in the skin as well
okay and in this case
um it starts when
they're younger ataxia
is not normal and it
won't get better right
so this is kid that's
not getting better
it's going to get
worse they have a history
of like pneumonias
sinusitis multiple
ear infections so
sinopulmonary issues all
right and the big thing
is that there's a
risk of long-term risk
of cancers because
this condition is a
genetic condition and it's
makes them susceptible
to chromosome break
breakages right
so here's a history
you know they get
Neurodegeneration, which
is manifest as ataxia,
sinopulmonary infections,
cancers, okay?
All right.
And one condition
that's always
compared, especially
on boards, is can you
tell the difference
between ataxia
and telangiectasia
and Friedrich's
ataxia? All right,
again, ataxia. It's
again, it's more
of a genetic issue.
They have
muscle weakness,
all right?
DTRs are affected,
all right? They have
some structural anomalies
such as high arched
feet or tamper toes.
And then the classic
thing I put in
highlight is a hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy,
all right? So
if you make this
diagnosis or you suspect
it, you definitely
want to get a
cardiology consult.
And that's, you
know, I've seen like
several times on board
questions already,
is knowing that
association between
phytrix ataxia and
cardiomyopathy, all right?
And in this case,
another thing that
helps you when you're
trying to figure
it out is that this
happens when they're
older versus ataxia
tantalagetasia
happens when they're
pretty young, that
this is starting, that
they're not right.
This is more like
something that
develops over
time and they
are 10 years old
or later, okay?
All right, that's it.
All right, I'm gonna
be with you for
neuro part two, but
here's a summary slide.
basically all the
I think all the
important points that
I think you should know
a couple of pages
of it and then look
over at your leisure
and please give a
feedback form it always
helps us helps me
improve my lectures
for the future and
then all right see
you in the next hour